l'agent à sa prise de service va
percevoir une caméra il va ensuite
inscrire les éléments de référence sur
le registre de perception c'est une
nouvelle habitude pour eric piot et ses
vingt agents de la police municipale de
montigny le bretonneux des caméras
piétons pour enregistrer leurs
interventions sur le terrain avec
surtout un aspect préventif si certaines
personnes pouvaient pouvait un certain
moment adopter un comportement plus ou
moins virulent ou injurieux je pense
qu'ils
réfléchir ont un petit peu avant et je
pense que les choses se passeront
beaucoup plus sereinement
la police municipale est équipé de six
caméras pour une période de test jusqu'à
juin 2010 huit coups de cet outil de
dissuasion 5000 euros investis par la
ville
une mesure nécessaire même si la commune
enregistre une tendance à la baisse de
la délinquance se détendent ce qu ont
été confirmées par la police nationale
donc donc ils sont qui sont fiables
après on a plutôt des des difficultés
ponctuelles à des endroits bien précis
aujourd'hui on constate certaines
évolutions par contre
mauvais comportement sur et aux abords
de la gare c'est une nouvelle caméra
s'inscrivent comme complément de
sécurisation avec d'autres dispositifs
déjà existants comme les pistolets à
impulsion électrique adopté également à
voisins le bretonneux